pünktlich zur adventszeit sind sie
wieder da die bettelbriefe in unseren
briefkasten
was tun sie damit spenden sie falls ja
sind sie der meinung sie spenden genug
oder halten sie die spende reiche einen
ablasshandel und beim rasieren sich
lieber politisch oder auch einfach
importiert tatsache ist menschen
verhungern haben keinen zugang zu
trinkwasser und medikamenten sterben auf
der flucht doch was geht sie und mich
dieses elend an
kein leichtes thema heute an unserem
video vision stammtisch zu dem ich sie
ganz herzlich begrüße wie auch unsere
stammgäste sind dies katrin noack aus
berlin
konrad paul liessmann aus wien und
diesmal mit von der partie stefan rehder
phonetik zentrum der universität zürich
ist auch philosoph und beschäftigt sich
sowohl privat persönlich auf auch
beruflich mit der frage wie sich die
welt verbessern lässt ganz herzlich
willkommen zum stammtisch diesmal sogar
mit kaffee und saft ich freue mich auf
die diskussion mit den weltverbesserern
setzt sich im moment auch eine serie von
srf talk auseinander die am letzten
freitag gestartet ist schauen wir kurz
rein als fotograf kommt manuel bauer dem
dalai lama dem geistigen oberhaupt
tibets so nahe wie kaum einer
seit jahren unterstützt er exil-tibeter
in indien und nepal ein dorfe zu seiner
größten herausforderungen
samson dass wegen der klimaerwärmung
bedroht ist er will es retten
das ganze dorf soll umziehen
manias neue witsch flüchtete als kind
vor dem bosnien krieg in die schweiz
jetzt hilft sie flüchtlingen aus syrien
irak und afghanistan wo sich andere
abwenden ist sie dafür menschen die
alles verloren haben
melanie holz gang ist ärzte
in äthiopien setzte sich für patienten
ein die einen unfall erlitten haben
hier wo auf eine million menschen ein
chirurg kommt muss sie schwerwiegende
entscheidungen treffen
[Musik]
philosoph bestens ausgebildet mit einem
doktortitel aus dem renommierten oxford
haben sie angesichts der
flüchtlingskrise je darüber nachgedacht
den elfenbeinturm einzutauschen gegen
ein flüchtlingscamp ein guter freund von
mir hat das gemacht er mit mir in oxford
studiert hat ist tatsächlich gegangen
nach calais vor einem guten jahr und
spätestens da habe ich mir auch überlegt
tatsächlich ob ich das machen sollte ich
habe es nicht getan das war zum teil
sicher aus bequemlichkeit weil es doch
erheblich was kostet das zu tun
er hat mir allerdings auch erzählt dass
es gar nicht so leicht war da etwas zu
tun also man ist da angekommen als
freiwilliger helfer
es gab sehr viele helfer er hat am ende
schwer gefunden dort in diesem camp
überhaupt etwas zu bewirken hat mit mit
leuten geredet dann am ende gekocht in
einer küche ich aber schon etwas womit
sie persönliche ringen und denken damit
auf jeden fall ich glaube allerdings es
gibt für mich vielleicht effektiver
weisen auch mich einzusetzen ich will
mich auch bemühen in meinem engagement
vielleicht so effektiv wie möglich zu
sein grundsätzlich und also auch wenn
ich ganz selbstlos gewesen wäre weiß ich
nicht ob ich in einem flüchtlingscamp
gehen würde
frauen newmark weltverbesserung ist das
eine rolle für sie haben sich dass man
überlegt als teenager bestimmt ich meine
natürlich hat jeder junge mensch oder
zumindest ich glaube sehr viele haben
das gefühl sie müssten etwas ändern
etwas verbessern und man hat dann all
diese träume und was man machen kann
also ein freiwilliger hilfe und auch an
politischer weltrevolution
selbstverständlich und ich muss gestehen
ich habe den eindruck dass das mit den
jahren nicht abgenommen hat sozusagen
die idee dass die welt und perfekt ist
und verbessert werden muss aber so die
vorstellung der möglichkeit davon also
das ist dann sozusagen von dem ich mache
eine revolution der teenagerjahre
übergewechselt ich spende irgendwie
spende hilfswerken also im internet eine
relativ distanzierte form also nicht
mehr in einer so
persönlich körperlich engagierte form
was ich in gewisser weise glaube ich
einfach sozusagen mit dem lauf des
lebens zu tun hatte mit den sehr vielen
anderen sachen die man zu tun hat
beschrieben und jetzt wissen auf sein
alter sich sagen so zu sagen ja herr
reden ob es doch ein bisschen älter
werden und wäre jetzt nicht an der
unterstellung an ihn aber ich beobachte
bei mir so eine zunehmende distanzierung
also nicht zum problem aber zudem der
forschung dass ich physisch persönlich
etwas machen könnte aber vielleicht und
ich glaube da wäre ich wahrscheinlich
mit herrn reden
es gibt es auch bessere arten als ich
als teenager ins getümmel zu stürzen
also effektivere wirkungsvoller der wert
weisen zu helfen
herr ließ man erst was für sie also ich
muss mich dem was war nun mal gesagt hat
ein bisschen anschließen
als ich jung war stand ja in meinem
horizont den horizont die weltrevolution
an der tagesordnung
jene weltrevolution die ein für alle mal
schluss machen sollte mit ausbeutung mit
armut elend mit diskriminierung die
menschen emanzipieren sollte sie
befreien sollte weltweit deshalb
weltrevolution wir haben solche welt
reparationen auch erlebt und aus einer
gewissen historischen erfahrung und
distanz ist man einfach ernüchtert
deshalb ist für mich weltverbesserung
kein programm mehr
ich will es anders formulieren
das geht vielleicht darum die welt ein
klein wenig erträglicher zu machen das
würde mir schon genug
sie spenden jahrzehnt ihres einkommen
sie haben sich dazu verpflichtet die
eine art versprechen das sie abgegeben
haben im rahmen ihrer mitgliedschaft bei
gw what we can
das ist eine organisation bei dem man
eben entsprechend auch herausfinden kann
wie man spenden soll aber zu denen auch
gehört 10 bis ans lebensende abzugeben
dann haben sie diesen entschluss gefasst
diesen entschluss habe ich ende
2011/anfang 2012 gefasst als ich eben in
oxford war für mein studium ich habe da
diese bewegung kennen gelernt die auch
diese organisation gegründet hat kevin
what we can
ich hatte mich vorher lange
philosophisch mit der frage
auseinandergesetzt welche pflichten
haben wir angesichts der globalen armut
oder andere probleme auf der welt und
spannte seinen extrem schwierige frage
bin irgendwie auch nicht richtig
vorangekommen
ausschlaggebend war dann diese
gemeinschaft von leuten zu sehen die das
einfach machen also eine große gruppe
von menschen die zehn prozent mindestens
ihres einkommens spenden dadurch sehr
viel bewirken können und eigentlich es
sich wenig kosten lassen im alltag die
leben alle sehr sehr glücklich und das
hat eigentlich dann den ausschlag
gegeben für mich nicht
die findet das wunderbar die es auch
mitglied bei ping what you can und
unterstützt es wäre etwas für 17 prozent
ist ziemlich viel interessanter weise ja
eigentlich eine summe die in vielen
religiösen schriften auch festgesetzt
ist ja der zehnte sozusagen kennt man im
judentum dem christentum auch im islam
kennt man entsprechende anteile die zu
spenden sind
na ja ich komme aus österreich und in
diesem land hat dankenswerter weise der
staat es übernommen mir dieses geld
gleich abzunehmen
das ist 50 prozent steuern das ist
natürlich auch ein großteil der steuern
oder ein teil dieser steuern wird
natürlich auch für hilfsprojekte im in-
und im ausland für entwicklungshilfe
verwendet das ist nicht nur für
infrastruktur nicht mehr für
gesundheitswesen nicht nur für den
sozialstaat der auch hilfe für die armen
ist für die flüchten
etc sondern das ist ja ziemlich
umfassende besteuerung würde ich mal
sagen weshalb ich man muss das schon
überlegen natürlich ist hat steuer ja
prinzipiell hält ist sozusagen die
vorform von steuer gewesen ja hattstein
natürlich prinzipiell schon diesen
gedanken etwas beizutragen indem man
jetzt den bürgern bestimmten prozentsatz
abnimmt etwas beizutragen zur
herstellung von gerechtigkeit verhält na
ja vor allem im inland aber nicht nur
als in dem moment wo wir die kuh hilfe
programme hat ist es sozusagen sind
verpflichtet
man kann sich immer fragen völlig zu
recht ob diese gelder auch sinnfällig
eingesetzt werden und da gebe ich
sozusagen der kritik die von dieser
bewegung des effektiven all tourismus
formuliert wird durchaus recht der sehr
viele entwicklungsgelder versickern in
korruption oder in andere dunkle kanäle
dann muss man sehr darauf achten ja aber
auf der anderen seite wird ich aus
verschiedensten gründen so sehr ich das
unglaublich sympathisch finde und alt
ist ich finde würde ich jetzt
philosophische die frage stellen ob es
tatsächlich solche pflicht zum spenden
gibt verpflegt diesen ganz starker
begriff ja wenn ich sage wer freiwillig
das will er weil er eben diese
sympathien hat weil das bedürfnis hat
auf diese art und weise zu heben von
weißem nicht stört das hat sozusagen
doppelt zahlt steuern plus spenden soll
es tun aber eine pflicht anspruch daraus
zu machen es noch mal ganz was anderes
lassen wir den pflicht das bett man noch
ganz kurz beiseite ich möchte noch mehr
wissen was zu dieser steuer geschichte
zu sagen ist reicht das will ich einfach
die steuern zu bezahlen
ich sehe es hängt schon von der höhe der
steuern ab
aber man muss eben was ich interessant
finde ist schon die frage wie viel von
diesen steuern wird wo eingesetzt und
ich glaube zum beispiel für
entwicklungshilfe wird verhältnismäßig
wenig eingesetzt zb in den usa glaube
ich ist es ungefähr ist weniger als ein
prozent des
finanzhaushalts hatte als ziel war ja
mal 0,7 im rahmen der millennium
development goals das hat man in vielen
vielen staaten verfehlt auch in der
schweiz erwägen wir sind nicht
angenommen und das finde ich schon
bemerkenswert also das beschäftigt mich
persönlich zu sehen in wie viel luxus
wir hier leben und dann die tatsache
dass wir 0,7 prozent davon abgeben an
die menschen die es nötig hätten den wir
so viel gutes türken könnten dadurch in
das finde ich schon bemerkenswert
abgesehen noch von der frage ob er eine
pflicht haben aber das ist muss man
schon bedenken glaube ich wurde schon
mehrere male die bewegung des effektiven
auflösung von ihnen allen erwähnt der
effektiven treffens in eine bewegung
sozusagen die gutes besser tun wollen so
heißt dieses buch auch von william ak
steel der philosoph aus oxford der eben
diese bewegung mit gegründet hat sie
haben mit dem studiert haben es bereits
erwähnt die sendung eco das
wirtschaftsmagazin hat zwei effektive
autisten begleitet auf ihrem weg
sozusagen die welt zu verbessern
die verdienen ihr geld unter anderem
auch mit dem ziel eben die welt zu
verbessern schauen wir uns diesen
beitrag
er hat letztes jahr 7700 franken
gespendet
ein zehntel seines einkommens der 26
jährige informatiker der eth zürich
findet aber ein gutes leben ohne
geldnöte er gelte es etwas abzugeben
der dozent für mich nicht so riesiger
betrag zum sv ist mehr oder weniger nach
dem studium hart fahren man merkt ihm
etat nicht zähler vor
aber wenn man sieht wie viele hunde die
verliebten ein verdammt hoch für dieses
auto ziemlich
[Musik]
stefan huber er hat letztes jahr 35.000
franken gespendet
ein drittel seines einkommens der
professionelle pokerspieler ist 29 und
gewinnt am pc und an turnieren
erhebliche summen
warum aber neue bedürfnisse schaffen nur
weil man mehr geld habe er zwar gerne
reise also seine hobbys aber
gleichzeitig gingen wir auf mehr
ressourcen für restlose genial man
selber verbraucht und der rest vom geld
ja glaube nicht dass es sich da mehr
glück aus den usa holen wenn ich selten
für mich bruch und einfach viel er war
später andere wo mit einem film ins
rennen
beide bezeichnen sich als effektiver
altruisten das ziel der bewegung hohe
summen spenden und sie nach
wissenschaftlichen kriterien vergeben um
möglichst viel zu bewirken vor allem zur
bekämpfung von krankheiten und armut in
entwicklungsländern
herr liefen am bewundernswert es ist
zumindest anständig gar keine frage wenn
jemand sozusagen diese vorstellungen hat
und danach lebt respekt ich habe nur
einige prinzipielle anmerkungen oder
zweifel ob das wirklich so funktioniert
meine erste frage ist für mich ob man
glücklich so einfach feststellen kann
was effektive hilfe ist also dieses
problem was ist wirklich effizient bei
hilfeleistungen führte dazu und diese
ganze diskussion des effektiven
altruismus ist auch gekennzeichnet davon
dass man natürlich schon
unterschiedliche formen von leidvoller
erfahrung von krankheit von
lebenserwartung von lebensqualität
zuerst einmal bemessen muss
qualifizieren muss und dann abwägen muss
und bei jedem beispiel könnte man
natürlich gegenbeispiele bringen die
zeigen also jetzt ist es wirklich
effektiv das geld hier einzusetzen und
nicht dort einzusetzen und ich kommen
diese und juristischen diskussionen was
ist effektiver ein menschenleben zu
retten drei menschenleben zu retten ein
junges oder ein
das welche krankheiten sind
schwerwiegend welches in weniger
schwerwiegend warum ist der arme vor
meiner haustür nicht so wichtig als fünf
kranke kinder in afrika
die seite ist diese außenperspektive der
immer hier mitschwingt ist für mich
vorerst mal nicht unbedingt wirklich
plausibel und das zweite was mir
irgendwie so durch den kopf geht
vergisst und fragen
das ist auch die organisationen er die
hier dann promotet werden
ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich
wissenschaftlich ist wie gesagt wurde
oder ob das nicht sozusagen eine form
ist wie sagen wir mal einer einer einer
investitionspolitik des guten ja wobei
ich mich also fragen würde ob
investitionspolitik auf dieser ebene
überhaupt was gutes sein kann
wer also viele punkte haben sie
angesprochen ich glaube auch wichtige
punkte zum beispiel es ist natürlich in
der tat schwierig das herauszufinden
welche organisationen sind jetzt die
effektivsten und es geht ja auch nicht
nur um spenden glaubt auch das wäre
verkürzte effektiver tourismus
interessiert sich auch durchaus für
andere formen des sozialen oder
politischen engagements und da wird es
noch schwieriger herauszufinden welche
leuchten bringen was am meisten bringt
welche formen des engagements jetzt
effektiv sind aber ich glaube was
interessant ist an dieser bewegung ist
sie darauf dass sie darauf antwortet mit
einem versuch und sagt ja wir müssen
halt so gut es geht jetzt versuchen
rauszufinden was das beste ist natürlich
können wir es nicht wissen und können
wir nicht zweifelsfrei feststellen
und es gibt durchaus methoden wie man
die man da rangehen kann also eine
methode die oft angewendet wird ist
randomisierte kontrollierte studien das
ist ein sehr sehr gängige prozedur
bereits in der medizin wenn man
herausfinden möchte ob ein medikament
funktioniert dann macht man
kontrollgruppen die man nach
zufallsprinzip einteilt von leuten die
man natürlich vorher gefragt hat ob sie
an dem test teilnehmen wollen und
verteilt dann das medikament an manche
gruppen und dann andere nicht und schaut
ob das medikament etwas hilft und
genauso kann man vorgehen auch in der
entwicklungshilfe also zum beispiel
wurde das gemacht in bezug auf
scholl schule bildungsproblematik dass
man versucht hat zu schauen was hilft
eigentlich dazu beizutragen dass dass
die kinder mehr in die schule gehen weil
es ein großes problem in
entwicklungsländern dass auch wenn
schulen existieren die kinder nicht
rangehen und dann kann man studien
machen mit kontrollierten gruppen und
überprüfen gehen die leute mehr wenn man
zum beispiel schon uniformen finanziert
oder gehen sie mehr wenn man zusätzliche
schulen zusätzliches schulmaterial zur
verfügung stellt gehen sie mehr wenn man
zusätzliche lehrpersonen anstellt und
das kann man ziemlich wissenschaftlich
untersuchen und dabei rauskommt dann
dass all diese methoden die ich jetzt
genannt habe ein bisschen was bringen
aber gar nicht so viel und das zb
entwurmung unglaublich effektiv ist also
wenn man für wenig geld die kinder impft
gegen würmer führt das dazu dass sie
weniger an würmer leiten und dass sie
unglaublich viel mehr ja auch eine der
organisationen die elektromotoren von
dieser organisation entwurmung von
kindern scheint unglaublich viel zu
bringen für sozusagen das bildungsniveau
dann in den entsprechenden ländern
ich möchte an dieser stelle eine frage
eines zuschauers einbringen die uns
vorab zugestellt worden ist war das
glaube ich noch ein stück weit das noch
steht verstärkt was sie immer ein
talisman mario studie aus und fragt das
folgende provokant gefragt was ist
effektiver rettung eines lebens vor
unmittelbaren hungertod oder
verbesserung eines nicht unmittelbar
gefährden leben sie ihn richtig
wohnsituation bildung schutz vor gewalt
das ist jetzt ein vergleich der gar
nicht so sehr die empirie betrifft
sondern eigentlich eine norm ab und das
ist eine normativ frage das ist auch
eine schwierige frage selbstverständlich
die frage quasi quantität gegen qualität
ich glaube und die allermeisten
definitiven an touristen würden
wahrscheinlich zustimmen man muss beides
abwägen dass es geht um lebensqualität
natürlich aber auch um um lebensdauer
und -qualität es gibt in der ökonomik
durchaus methoden wie man das machen
kann
aber ich möchte auch sagen das sind oft
auch detail fragen jetzt genau dieses
abwägen zwischen ein bisschen länger
leben oder ein bisschen mehr an einer
krankheit leiden weil oft geht es
wirklich darum rette ich also verbessere
ich das leben eines menschen hier
ein wenig oder rette ich hunderte von
menschenleben an das wohnen dann in
solchen situationen würde ich schon
sagen dass wir sagen können was jetzt
effektiver ist ja und ich glaube ich
meine vielleicht muss man nochmal
grundsätzlich daran setzen es gibt
sozusagen im detail sehr viele
diskussionen was ist effektiver und wie
sollten wir uns verhalten aber der grund
skandal an dem sich diese leute
aufhängen und da haben sie einfach recht
ist dass wir in einer welt in der wir
leben so viele menschen an hunger
sterben und an vermeidbaren krankheiten
und dass wir dafür keine lösung gefunden
haben und da ein großes beispiel was die
effektiven alltours man ja dann trösten
ja auch immer vertreten ist diese
moskitonetze die unglaublich effizient
sind darin malaria zu bekämpfen und die
sind auch sehr billig zu verteilen und
dass wir sozusagen in unser entwickelten
und reichen welt keine methode gefunden
haben große bevölkerungsschichten vor
dem tod an hunger oder vermeidbaren
krankheiten zu retten das ist ein
skandal
und natürlich kann man sagen man darf
sich darauf nicht allein konzentrieren
man muss auch auf lebensqualität auf
bildung auf soziale aufstiegschancen auf
politische veränderungen drängen das ist
alles richtig aber dass man
grundsätzlich mal diesen skandal sieht
und auch sagt da müssen wir in den
reichen ländern einfach meinetwegen ein
zehntel oder was immer unseres
einkommens daran geben dass dieser
skandal man auch mal aus der welt
verschwindet dass das ist etwas was ich
nicht nur rational argumentieren kann
sondern auch ganz emotional richtig
finde
warum warum läuft das ganze so das haben
einige leute und auch geschrieben gesagt
haben
jetzt redet ihr wieder immer wird
gelagert wird gesagt über das problem
der welt armut wir unterhalten uns hier
schön herren geht nach hause und spendet
weiterhin zehn prozent wir machen
wahrscheinlich so wahnsinnig viel für
seinen 18 prozent dass das wäre ja der
witz also das und ich finde schon mehr
man sich mit dieser bewegung
auseinandersetzt desto mehr sieht man
eigentlich nicht mehr ein warum man das
nicht tun sollte also da wird es
persönlich geht es so und ich kenne es
auch wirklich von anderen leuten also
wenn man mal diese ein bisschen da rein
liest einmal ein vorteil von willi marx
erste sich anschaut dann denkt man
wirklich warum macht man das nicht es
gibt keinen grund dafür
es gibt schon einige gründe bitte das
eine ist was sie vorher schon sagte wenn
wir es tun will soll es tun was anderes
ist als das gleichsam zur pflicht
erklären kann man vielleicht noch später
diskutieren
aber was was nicht gestört hat so war
der lektüre also jetzt wie sie das
angedeutet haben ist versetzen wir
unseres effektiv als touristen nicht in
eine unglaubliche ich sag's noch etwas
blasphemisch gottähnliche position
ich entscheide ja durch meinen beitrag
durch meine spende die effizient
eingesetzt werden wird nach einem
letztlich dann doch und militaristische
ökonomischen kalkül
du sollst leben und du nicht oder du
sollst am leben bleiben muss erst
schauen wir weiter kosten weekend wir
können nicht ja auch wenn jetzt alle
effektiv an touristen werden würden
können wir sozusagen die welt nicht
retten und dass der eine punkt der
zweite punkt ist also das ist so ist das
für mich nicht mehr an maßen positionen
wenn ihr gerade davon schweiz nicht weil
gespendet werden
was ich auch tue sondern die anmaßung
besteht gerade in dieser vermeintlichen
rational agiert die dahinter treiben
scheint die ich nicht teile aber die
frage ist doch dass wir einfach
entscheiden müssen also die probleme
sind so groß dass wir mit unseren
gegebenen ressourcen eben nicht alle
probleme lösen kann nicht alle menschen
retten können das heißt wir müssen die
entscheidung treffen wir uns dann halt
begründung strategie des musik sprache
mentalität aber ich glaube das machen
wir durchaus in ganz ganz vielen kontext
also zum beispiel ich war nur schon
verkehrspolitik wenn ich zwei
verkehrsknotenpunkte habe wo es immer
wieder zu unfällen kommt dabei im einen
knotenpunkt kommt es zu tödlichen
unfällen pro jahr im anderen knotenpunkt
kommt alle fünf jahre zur tödlichen
unfall nicht muss mich entscheiden wo
sich unsere ressourcen alternative aber
das ist ja selbstverständlich das ist
das prinzip der garage und ich meine das
kann man eine anmaßung nennen aber es
ist schlecht und einfach was ein arzt
jeden tag tut also beziehungsweise ein
arzt in einer krisensituation muss
sozusagen entscheiden welchem patienten
muss zuerst geholfen werden beim
verkehrsknotenpunkt und ich glaube auch
bei all den problemen dieser welt und
natürlich kann man darüber sehr viel
diskutieren welches problem wie und
dringlich ist
aber und ein problem der rationalisten
ist ja sozusagen das sich rational
diskutieren wollen habe ich glaube ich
ein emotional kann man auch gewisse
punkt selbst auf einer emotionalen ebene
gewisse probleme als superzahl es ist
ein punkt nicht einfach derjenige dass
man den eindruck kriegt es hat ein
bisschen was herz loses auch wenn man
grundsätzlich das ganze vernünftig
versteht sie bringen ja in einem
interview mit esskultur das vorgängig
geführt worden ist das beispiel dass sie
sagen wenn man einen blindenhund
ausbilden lässt in der schweiz kostet
das ungefähr 50000 franken mit dem
gleichen geld könnte man 500 kinder oder
menschen vor dem erblinden retten jetzt
denke ich natürlich sofort ja wenn ich
doch blinde in der schweiz sehe möchte
ich doch dass den blindenhund haben und
sich doch nicht verkehrt wenn ich einen
blindenhund finanziere
sagen wir mal für mein nachbarsmädchen
dass ich keinen blinden hund leisten
kann
da kriege ich so den eindruck helfen hat
auch viel damit zu tun unmittelbar
berührt zu sein
ich halte das tatsächlich für ein großes
moralisches problem ich glaube ein
problem besteht einfach darin dass wir
diese personen hat nicht sehen die da
täglich sterben die kennen die
statistiken wir kennen die zahlen wie
viele leute da leiden an krankheiten wie
viele sterben aber das ist alles so weit
weg sind nur zahlen wir sehen das nicht
und ich halte es ehrlich gesagt die rein
geografische distanz dass das nun mal
nicht hier passiert und vor meinen augen
passiert moralisch gesehen für nicht
besonders relevant und ich versuche dann
mir das vorzustellen und damit zu fühlen
was bedeutet das dass so viele leute da
sterben und ich glaube wenn ich wenn ich
versuche mir das vorzustellen dann hat
das durchaus auch was mit empathie und
mitgefühl zu tun und dann muss ich sagen
ja wenn die wenn die hier wären und ich
würde das sehen wie all diese menschen
ist dann wäre es keine frage dieser
stelle brauchen hier peter singer glaube
ich peter singer hat auch ein buch
geschrieben für über den effektiven
tourismus aber er hat auch das berühmte
beispiel entworfen und geht es gerade
darum geht das beispiel ist schon uralt
von 1972 in seinem ersten grossen
aufsatz zum thema welt armut und in
diesem dass dieses beispiel haben die
auch animiert im rahmen der srf reihe
philosophisch zu philosophischen
gedanken experimenten schauen wir uns
dieses beispiel kurz an
heute bist du eine berühmte professorin
du hast dich zurecht gemacht neuer
designeranzug neue lackschuhe in 15
minuten beginnt deine vorlesung auf dem
weg zum vorlesungssaal kommst du an
einem teich vorbei doch was ist das
ohne zu überlegen springst du in den
teich und rettet das kind anzug und
schuhe sind ruiniert
die vorlesung ist im eimer
doch der ist vollkommen klar du hast das
einzig richtige getan
das leben des kindes wiegten am zug die
schuhe und eine erfolgreiche vorlesung
bei weitem auf nach deiner
rettungsaktion kommst du nach hause und
findet den briefkasten post von einer
entwicklungsorganisation sie ruft dazu
auf für die hungernden kinder in nigeria
zu spenden
mit 10 franken sicherste die ernährung
eines kindes für einen ganzen monat
ansonsten würde der junge sterben
spendet du
wenn nicht weshalb springst du in den
teich und opfers teure markenkleider für
das leben eines kindes spende ist aber
keine zehn franken für ein kind in
afrika
das ist doch nicht das gleiche sagst du
warum eigentlich nicht
endlich mal ist es das gleiche das ist
ein berühmtes beispiel und wir
diskutieren jetzt fast vier jahrzehnte
über dieses beispiel ich vertrete er die
position ist nicht das gleiche was und
zwar aus zwei gründen das eine ist was
mich sozusagen an dessen unmittelbaren
hilfe akt und deren analyse und
bewertung hier bei diesem teich
beispiele das stört ist dass er sofort
wieder auf die frage einer güterabwägung
reduziert wird ja also lackschuhe gegen
das leben eines kindes ich glaube das
ist das falsche argument darum geht es
gar nichts was geht um das leben des
kindes und die kann nicht sagen also
wenn es eine güterabwägung ist hab ich
lackschuhe okay das erleben das kind ist
wichtiger anzug das leben als kind ist
wichtiger aber wann sind die güter für
mich so wichtig wenn zum beispiel die
5000 franken die ich da und spenden
könnte jetzt durch diesen hilfseinsatz
vernichtet werden würden dass ein leben
des kindes aber mit 5000 franken kann
ich habe bekanntlich wie das beispiel
zeigt so viele kinder in afrika retten
da dürft ihr dann nicht mehr einspringen
also das ist für mich schief ist der
eine punkt und das zweite der zweite
punkt im gegensatz zu ihnen denke ich
sehr wohl dass distanz sowohl räumliche
distanz als auch emotionale distanz
moralische kategorie ist das heißt also
wir dürfen nicht den selben fehler
verfallen die die sozusagen bestimmte
ökonomen ihn gemacht haben den menschen
gleichsam als rationaler homo ökonomen
kuster zu konstruieren und jetzt heißt
genauso nationalen homo etikett zu
konstruieren für den gleichsam jedes
menschenleben gleich viel wert ist egal
wo es ist ein wahrhaft beziehungen zu
müssen und dergleichen mehr so
funktionieren so leben menschen einfach
nicht und deswegen denke ich dass auch
wenn man jetzt bringt sie geglaubt
das ist richtige ist hier zu helfen hier
zu spenden auch dort wo man es keine
unmittelbare beziehung hat bedarf es
mehr als einer rationalen überlegungen
vielleicht noch noch einen punkt wenn
jetzt schon ganz wie schon das ist das
ist klar
arnold geht und sagt das schon der
mensch hat kein organ für fern ethik es
ist klar wir haben natürlich ist ein
anderer fall und ich glaube auch dass es
ein anderer fall dass eines nothilfe und
das andere ist hilfe sozusagen die nicht
aus einem jetzt direkt vor augen stehen
notfall erwächst aber ich glaube was
wichtig ist ist dass der effektive
altruismus nicht unbedingt als eine
ideologie gesehen wird der wir der die
ganze welt unterliegen soll sondern ihr
also etwas wie ein korrektiv einer
effektiven tourismus ist überhaupt nicht
festgelegt legen wir auf die these ich
muss jetzt alles rational handeln bei
jedem leben genau gleich viel
moralisches gewicht beimessen zum
beispiel meinen kindern verwandten genau
gleich viel die irgendwas gibt so sind
diese aber nicht alle effektiven
allerhöchsten sehen das so ich
persönlich weiß es auch nicht aber ich
glaube das muss man auch schon gar nicht
weit also wir müssen es uns mal
irgendwie auf der zunge zergehen lassen
wie unterschiedlich einfach die zahlen
sind also ob ich 100 personen davon
bewahre blind zu werden oder ob ich eine
person einen blindenhund finanzieren
kann
das sind einfach schon große zahlen die
mich persönlich durchaus beeindrucken
und auch wenn ich sage ich habe
vielleicht noch ein bisschen stärkere
verpflichtung den leuten in meiner
nachbarschaft gegenüber dass sie so so
viel stärker ist das bezweifle ich
einfach weil die zahlen sind enorm und
vielleicht noch etwas die wissen
gefühlen also es hat irgendwie auch
einfach seit jeher die aufgabe der
moralphilosophie darin bestanden auch
unsere emotionen unsere malischen
emotionen kritisch zu reflektieren also
wahrscheinlich gab es oder zu
kultivieren oder auch oder zu
kultivieren auf eine weise also
wahrscheinlich haben viele leute ist
nicht als eklatante ungerechtigkeit
unmittelbar empfunden dass manche leute
als sklaven gehandelt wurden oder dass
das frau und weniger rechte hatten als
männer und immer hat die aufgabe der
philosophie auch darin bestanden
unsere gefühle zu kritisieren zu
reflektieren und zu kultivieren und ich
stelle mir manchmal vor wenn die leute
in 100 jahren zurück schauen auf unsere
zeit in 200 jahren gibt es so etwas wie
einen großen moralischen skandal unserer
zeit wie es vielleicht zu sein
das klappt aber nicht glaube unser
verhältnis gegenüber den armen könnte
ein großer moralischer skandal sein wir
dürfen nicht so leichtfertig
da unsere emotionen einfach vertrauen
habe ich glaube ich vorgehen ganz genau
ich möchte herrn ließen und auch in
einem punkt recht geben dass ich oder
zumindest habe ich da auch verstehe ich
herrn ließ man sie ja gut nämlich dass
sie jetzt gesagt haben na ja das ist mir
so ein korrektiv aber gerade wenn man
single ist es natürlich nicht einfach
ein korrektiv sondern dass ich eine
moral brille aufs leben partout da gibt
es ein kapitel drehen darf man kinder
haben eigene kinder haben und er kommt
zum schluss der beschreibt eine frau die
als er bewundert die heißt julia und
diese frau entscheidet sich keine kinder
zu haben weil das ist zeigen die
ökologisch gesehen eine
ressourcenverschwendung außerdem auch
energie und geld wenn schon müsste man
kinder adoptieren
und dann wird die frau unglaublich
unglücklich und sie entscheidet sich
dann doch ein kind zu haben weil dann
hat sie auch genügend energie dann doch
genug gutes zu tun
aber es ist alles durch diese brille
betrachtet da muss ich sagen ja
eigene kinder haben das darf man doch
wohl noch oder nein das darf man das
haben wir auch gemacht das ist okay und
ich glaube ja eigentlich hinter ihm
kostet soviel geld ja aber das hätte man
wahrscheinlich 1000 kinder in der dritt
ist ein wunderbares leben möglich sein
was hier ein halb so kleines kind mitten
in der schweiz verbraucht wenig zu
denken
da ist ich glaube das ist etwas was
gerade diese bewegung auch so
interessant macht das ja eine gewisse
offenheit zulässt also die peter singer
ist ein und elitär ist jung tourismus
ist die philosophische position dass man
in jedem einzelnen moment die handlung
tunes also die das beste bewirkt und
peter singer glaubt dass aber der
effektiven tourismus behauptet das nicht
ganz viel effektiver touristen die auch
zugeben wir haben das recht bis zu einem
gewissen grad unser leben zu leben und
wir wissen nicht jede einzelne
entscheidung diesen kriterien
unterwerfen und ich glaube wir werden
von eine falsche alternative gestellt
wenn es hieß entweder jeder
einzelne lebensentscheidung unter dieses
effektivitäts kriterium zu stellen oder
gar nicht das kriterium
also ich würde auch noch sagen wenn ich
effektiven altruismus einen
interessanten ansatz finde dann bedeutet
das nicht dass ich in eine kirche
eintrete deren pfarrer geht es sicher
ist also muss man klar sagen wir sind
hier philosophen oder lang auch die ich
glaube auch die menschen die nicht
professionell philosophie betreiben der
witz an philosophie oder an
philosophischen denkens ist dass man
gute gedanken kritisch prüft und ich
finde da sind sehr viele gute gedanken
drin
es ist auch wirklich in diesem kalkül
richtig dass wir keine eigenen kinder
haben sollten jetzt gibt aber andere
gründe die dafür sprechen dass wir doch
welche haben wollen und dann machen wir
das auch das heißt ich bin doch als
philosophin und auch als nicht
philosophin durchaus fähig diese
wirklich zum teil sehr guten ideen zu
übernehmen ohne jede einzelne konsequenz
oder ohne jede position von herrn singer
zu übernehmen also da habe ich überhaupt
kein problem damit
na ja es geht ja nicht nur das gerät
nicht nur um geschmacksfragen er also
philosophisch interessant wird dass wir
eine theorie überhaupt erst an wenn es
einer bestimmten verbindlichkeiten kann
nämlich verbindlichkeit anspruch jetzt
sowohl in theoretischer hinsicht es ist
ja nichts was einfach gesagt wird
irgendeine gute ideen schaut euch die
ran vielleicht gefällt vielleicht
gefällt soll ich nicht also kann ich im
bereich der brust argumentieren aber
nicht im bereich der philosophie
das heißt es theoretisch konsistent sein
damit argumentiert da ist und das zweite
ist natürlich und bei zynga ist das ganz
stark deswegen die wunde ich ihnen auch
wenn er wirklich konsequent ist er denkt
dass zu ende ist schon gewissen grad ist
das ist das ganz stark wer sich nicht an
diese vorgaben des effektiven altruismus
hält der führt nicht ein anderes leben
sondern der für den moralisch falsch es
leben und das ist eine ganz starke these
die aber konsequent ist die moral ist ja
für sich gesehen nur dann wirklich
interessant wenn sie an bestimmten
universalisierung anspruch hat also
tatsächlich für alle gelten können soll
da wird es für mich dann höchst
problematisch wenn man eine solche
erstens widersprüche kommt und wenn ich
dann höre dass man trotzdem lediger
weise zugestanden wird bis zu einem
gewissen grad auch mein leben führen zu
können
da stellt sich intuitiv alles
ebenso führen ohne dass mir ein
effektiver als tourist denn grad
vorschreibt bis zu dem ich es führen
kann ehrlich gesagt was nichts dagegen
spricht dass ich ihn und wider von
vorhin gesagt genauso spenden aktiv bin
und übrigens keine kinder habe aber muss
ich sorge um das ökologische
gleichgewicht dieser erde
aber da muss man glaube ich schon jetzt
eben auch wieder ein diesmal recht geben
gemeint mit dem effektiven autoriesen es
ist ja nicht wenn du helfen willst also
wenn du dir überlegst einen spenden
brief jetzt positiv zu beantworten dann
tust doch auch irgendwie möglichst
effektiv sondern sich ja schon verbunden
mit einem appell möglichst viel gutes zu
tun die frage ist wie weit geht diese
maximierung cd darf man auch noch die
eigene familie bevorzugen aber es gibt
ganz klar die sind diese pflicht idee
dagegen würde sich als manga wären also
was sie damals gibt eine pflicht wir
haben eine pflicht zu spenden
ich persönlich glaube wir müssen ernst
nehmen auch eben wie sie gerade gesagt
haben es ist eine bewegung es ist keine
philosophie ist es eine soziale bewegung
die auch keine bis ins letzte detail
ausgearbeitete philosophie hat wie das
philosophen peter singer haben und ich
glaube das ist auch das interessante er
brauche so nicht gesehen haben wie eine
pflicht ich möchte noch etwas sagen
nämlich für die für die bewegung selbst
spielte pflicht begriff auch keine so
wichtige rolle also sie gehen nicht rum
und so erzählen den leuten ihr habt ja
eine pflicht und ihr müsst es spenden
sondern und das war auch in meinem fall
so wie die allermeisten leute zu dieser
bewegung kommen ist dass sie zunächst
einmal einfach sehen wie unglaublich
viel wir tun können wenn wir es auf
effektive weise tun einerseits und wie
wenig es uns eigentlich kostet also dass
man ein wunderbares ein sehr zufriedenes
leben führen kann
auch wenn man sich engagiert und da muss
man den pflicht begriff noch gar nicht
erst wenn sie jetzt in ihrem umfeld
leute haben sie sagen weißt du was
interessiert mich alles überhaupt nicht
nützt den übrigen auch nichts darüber
könnten wir nachher noch sprechen ist es
eigentlich überhaupt die richtige art
und weise gutes zu tun aber einfach
jemand der sagt interessiert mich alles
nicht geht nicht auch nichts an
ich meine die eine frage ist machen sie
der person eine vor ein vorwurf dass
vielleicht auch eine frage
möglichkeit für die andere frage ist wie
denken sie darüber denken sie nicht
diese person begeht einen moralischen
fehler
also es kommt jetzt darauf an was das
für eine person ist aber ich gleich
würde schon sagen wollen wir haben ein
ich würde auch sagen wollen wir haben
durchaus bestimmte pflichten ich glaube
unser reichtum stellt uns bis zu einem
gewissen grad zumindest unter eine
pflicht also ich habe jetzt im als
vorbereitung für diese sendung zum
beispiel nachgeschaut was uhren kosten
von berühmten schweizer uhrenmarken an
die man an der bahnhofstraße kaufen kann
und da gibt es einfach sehr sehr schnell
uhren für 15 15000 franken und die gehen
bis im sechsstelligen bereich
und irgendwie ich weiß nicht das scheint
mir einfach auf eine weise ein skandal
zu sein wenn man bedenkt dass man für
3500 franken einen menschenleben retten
könnte und ich würde sagen gewisse
pflichten auf unseren luxus zu
verzichten haben wir durchaus wie weit
sie gehen finde ich wie fragen gemacht
ich glaube ich muss jetzt doch
irgendwann gewissens anmelden mit ihnen
beiden auch sowohl was den ethik-
begriff als auch die philosophie begriff
betrifft also weil ein es ist klar dass
natürlich eine philosophie oder ethik
intern den anspruch haben mag eine
verpflichtung für alle herzustellen zu
sein so karen zu sein dass es für die
menschheit als ganzes gelten kann
jetzt möchte ich einfach darauf
verweisen dass die philosophie in den
letzten 5000 oder dreitausend jahre oder
wie immer man das ansetzen war nicht so
wahnsinnig viel dazu beigetragen hat die
menschheit in ihre richtung zu lenken
also philosophie ist in diesem sinne
nicht das was die menschen anleitet in
ihrem handeln das heißt eine ethik ist
also die philosophie mögen sich gerne
vorstellen dass das was sie tun dann
eine handlungsanweisung für menschen ist
ist es aber praktisch im praktischen
falle nie und darum muss man mit
philosophie da hab ich auch anders
umgehen also seine ist sich zu freuen
über ein ethisch korrektes system wo ist
dann wirklich so ist dass die masken und
die hilfs pflichten die man darin auf
stellt für alle gelten könnten und auch
von allen akzeptiert akzeptiert würden
das andere ist sich in der realen welt
um zu schauen und zu gucken was kann die
philosophie darin leisten und das finde
ich ist wirklich ganz andere sache und
da finde ich eben den effektiven
altruismus interessant weil es
philosophen sind die in der wirklichen
welt etwas bewegen indem sie nämlich
richtig organisationen gründen und ganz
konkret diese studien
welche spenden formen helfen das kann
mir dann finde ich eine pragmatische
hilfestellung und dann ist es eben so
dass man dann nicht unbedingt ein die
einer philosophisch kohärenten idee
folgen muss sondern hier wird einfach
eine eine philosophisch auch rationale
argumentierte so zu sein denk hilfe
angeboten mit der ich meinem selbst
verhältnis und in meinem welt verhältnis
etwas eine richtung geben kann und erst
mal so wie ganz also nicht zu sein an
dem philosophischen gradmesser dessen
ist das korrekt und könnte das für alle
menschen gelten sondern nur kann dass
uns ein wegweiser sein wie wir besser
helfen besser spenden wie wir diesen
gruppen umgehen
vielleicht einfach nur ganz kurz weil
weil sie mich jetzt auch konkret
angesprochen haben ich glaube ich würde
durchaus sagen natürlich glaube ich wir
haben eine pflicht übrigens findet man
die auch bei kommt die ist jetzt nicht
nur multi kulti gitarrist verankert nur
ich habe große probleme mit dieser
maximierung idee und würde glaube ich
einfach ja nichts man folgendes wenn man
so zu argumentieren beginnt ist es für
mich nicht so klar wie man sich im
aktivierungs idee unterbinden kann
aber mal ganz abgesehen davon finde ich
gibt es einfach noch diese
schwierigkeiten über die haben jetzt
noch gar nicht gesprochen nämlich
systemkritik versus spenden also diese
dieser ganze dieser ganze vorwurf dass
man sagt ja diese ganze spende rey wird
natürlich auch ein system
aufrechterhalten von dem wir uns
eigentlich distanzieren soll das gibt
neue untersuchungen beispielsweise von
der uno die besagen dass doppelt so viel
geld aus afrika heraus fließt in
steueroasen und dergleichen in
welthandels problematik von weltcups
problematik aufgefressen wird als gelder
die aus offizielle entwicklungshilfe
investiert werden und da muss man sich
doch fragen wie man dieses system wird
nicht aufrechterhalten
also man das ist wirklich früher schon
anmerken dass sie sich ganz so großes
problem
man ist ja auch kein neues problem
bisher nicht so dass die welt armut
jetzt erst heute entdeckt wird sondern
die gibt es schon sehr lange
die war übrigens vor 15 20 jahren größer
als heute
und wenn da etwas geändert hat daran das
sicher nicht dieses spendenaufkommen
nicht in erster linie das
spendenaufkommen der welt
also man hier in der schweiz von secret
zu zitieren hieße eulen nach athen
tragen aber dass das dass er hunger er
als system problem ist ja wie
nahrungsmittel wirtschaft funktioniert
wie spekulation mit nahrungsmitteln
funktioniert und nicht die frage ob
jetzt dort mehr oder weniger tausend
franken in geschickt werden nicht
hingeschickt werden
das kann man jetzt einfach ausklammern
wir schätzen auch ein bisschen
philosophisch naiv zu sein ehrlich
gesagt das ganze unter dieser ich meine
das ist sozusagen unsere ich sage mal
als geld zentristische weltsicht wir
sehen zwar ein problem
wir haben irgendein ökonomen der uns
sagt um dieses problem zu lösen bräuchte
man so viel geld und das legen wir daran
um wenn es wirklich das ging wirklich
darum ginge dann genügte es ja dann
genügt es die 60 menschen
die zwei drittel des geldvermögens
dieser erde besitzen for mac diesmal
tourismus zu überzeugen oder nur teile
davon zu überzeugen und wir hätten alle
probleme der welt gelöst
auch wenn die das alles spenden würden
wird mehr zurückzucken und nach ein paar
jahren und werden feststellen wir haben
überhaupt keine probleme der welt gelöst
das heißt also da geht mir einfach der
analyse in das was jetzt ökonomie was
soziales leben was politik was
erwartungen was hoffnungen ängste
konflikte und dergleichen er betrifft
viel zu wenig tief da waren wir bei
einer kritischen gesellschaft zur
theorien gesellschaftsanalyse die gerade
diese frage individuelle hilfe versus
das systemkritik mal gestellt hat waren
wir eigentlich schon mal weiter dass ich
möchte sagen dass es wurde zum beispiel
den beitrag in der einspielung über
effektive art touristen so dargestellt
im effektiven alle touristen altruismus
geht es darum möglichst hohe summen zu
spenden und das ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht die grundidee sondern die
grundidee ist genau die wir müssen ganz
genau schauen welche form des
engagements bewirkt am meisten und und
wenn es sich herausstellt wenn man wenn
man zeigen kann oder argumentieren kann
das politisches engagement viel viel
mehr bewirkt auch längerfristig dann
wären die effektiven touristen die alle
allerersten die da umschwenken also es
ist historisch belegt gewesen
die bewegung viel gearbeitet zu armut
aber der grundgedanke ist natürlich
überhaupt nicht spenden oder auch nicht
überhaupt globale armut sondern einfach
gutes tun was auch immer sich bei ihnen
der boss ist der posten review hat ein
anderer philosoph bereich hat die
bewegung kritisiert und gesagt mag sein
das sagen die effektiv naturisten immer
wenn es dann mehr helfen würde wären wir
auch politisch aktiv
tatsächlich kommen aber begriffe wie
machtverhältnisse politische institution
und so hat in diesen büchern eigentlich
praktisch nicht vor
und da geht so weit dass er sagt
demokratie an sich hat keine bedeutung
für die effektive touristen sondern wenn
sie das politische system ersetzen
könnten durch eine technokratie also am
ruder wären dann philosophen nicht alle
platten sondern technokraten die
ausrechnen können wie erreichen wir das
beste dann müssten wir die welt von
solchen technokraten regieren lassen
nicht demokratisch ich habe noch nicht
recht ich glaube er hat sicher ein
bisschen recht das ist sozusagen
soziologisch gesehen hat die bewegung
sich bisher sehr sehr stark konzentriert
auf armut und auf spenden unter anderem
einfach deswegen weil es hierzu die
meiste forschung gibt weil es da
leichter ist solche vergleiche
anzustellen was bewirkt wie viel aber
ich glaube er hat dadurch auch die die
sozusagen die bewegung selber hat ihren
eigenen maximen bisher noch nicht genüge
getan aber wir müssen auch sagen das ist
eine junge bewegung also ungefähr 2011
wurde die gegründet ist in fünf jahren
unglaublich gewachsen und sie hat auch
noch sehr viel potenzial und ich halte
das für einen der wichtigsten punkte
auch für die bewegung selber da noch
differenzierter zu werden also ich meine
ich würde diesen punkt mit der
systemkritik der mangelnden oder
sozialen nicht im zentrum stehen
durchaus recht geben insofern ist das
was hier propagiert wird natürlich
diesem teich beispiel verwandt es geht
immer um nothilfe also obwohl wir jetzt
sozusagen philosophisch unterscheiden
können zwischen nothilfe und hilfe
sozialen andere länder also zwischen
diesem aktuellen fall und und anderen
fällen ist doch so sind die haupt
baustelle des effektiven altruismus ist
doch immer das retten von menschenleben
sozusagen das oder nicht also die welt
machen beispiel viele gedanken über
probleme und gefahren von künstlicher
intelligenz und und denken dass das
könnte eine sehr effektive form des
engagements sein
risiken von künstlicher intelligenz zu
erforschen okay das ist noch mal was an
und sagen wir haben es ganz viele
aspekte warum tiere genau aber
landespolitiker verlieren so mag man
also die migrationspolitik da gebe ich
ihnen recht da gibt es tatsächlich so
sein ansätze auch dass man da wirklich
sich gedanken dazu macht weil er so eine
offenere welt wäre dass ich auch eine
gerechtere welt aber dieses klassische
sozialkritik und dass man tatsächlich
systematisch die die verhältnisse
verändern müssen das steht nicht im
fokus weil das natürlich auch also da
kann ich nicht einfach irgendwo schnell
zehntausend franken hin spenden und das
wirkt dann etwas also das ist natürlich
sehr viel komplizierter also ich glaube
darauf haben die auch wirklich keine
antwort da gibt es doch dann auch
gewisse kritik die geübt wird ja von dem
man sagen kann versteht man dann auch
nämlich der vorwurf der doppelmoral dass
man sagt wir nehmen mal gaskell plädiert
dafür an gewissen stellen in interviews
zum beispiel lieber ein billigprodukt zu
kaufen und nicht das fairtrade oder bio
produkt war er sagt unter umständen kann
man mit der differenz weil das ja so
viel günstiger ist das billigprodukt
kann man mehr bewirken man kann dieses
geld nämlich spenden und dann wird im
endeffekt mehr gutes dabei herauskommen
und war dadurch den eindruck von einer
einer doppelmoral hat den eindruck na ja
dass ich so ein bisschen man unterstützt
weiterhin einen unfairen handel
beispielsweise und gibt sich dann
großzügig und spendet wieder na ja also
ich finde es ist wichtig dass wir auch
über die situation bei fairtrade das
wieder kritisch nachdenken
ich weiß nicht ob all diese zahlen
stimmen das ist auch in der effektiven
an touristen sehr sehr umstritten ob
dieses argument funktioniert aber
macaskill sagt zum beispiel fairtrade
institutionen sind oft nicht in den
ärmsten ländern weil sich dort die
menschenrechtsstandards nicht leisten
können und deswegen wenn wir diese
produkte kaufen unterstützen wenig die
allerärmsten und es ist auch einfach
sehr sehr schwer heutzutage nicht teil
und irgendwie komplize eines ungerechten
systems zu sein weil praktisch alles was
man gerade da auch das nicht kauft um
anderen zu helfen dann die die noch
nicht von den allerärmsten gehören über
kurz oder lang sondern allerärmsten
gehören werden weder verdreht haben so
zusammen wenn jeder sich nach dieser
maxime und eher verhalten und die
einzige art und weise vielleicht nicht
teil eines ungerechten lohnsystems zu
sein ist produkte zu kaufen die hier in
der schweiz produziert werden zu fairem
lohn aber dann sind die einfach sehr
sehr teuer und macaskill argumentiert
dass damit den leuten zum beispiel die
in sweatshops arbeiten
tragischerweise auch nicht geholfen wird
weil dann diese firmen schließen müssen
diese produktionsstätten in
entwicklungsländer klimawandel sie
müssen alle diese kleider dann hierher
transportieren die baumwolle ins land
ickx und dass die den stoff ins nächste
loch da muss man muss nicht zahlen
anschauen es gibt auch statistiken dazu
dass zb transport eigentlich einen
relativ kleinen anteil ausmacht des
ökologischen fußabdrucks von von
produkten
aber ja ich möchte nur sagen wir müssen
wir müssen diese arbeit leisten wir
müssen kritisch bleiben auch diesen
ideen gegenüber die zunächst einmal gut
klingen und fragen hilft vertreten
der faktor das was es uns versprochen
hat ich möchte ich weiß nicht ob diese
zahlen stimmen aber es ist ein
interessantes argument an dem punkt muss
ich noch was anderes beispiel ganz kurz
zu sprechen kommen ja wo ich auch
entweder das problem habe wie wird hier
tatsächlich gemessen nämlich nicht nur
als fairtrade gegenüber was kann ich
weniger produkte kaufe dann retten
sondern es gibt auch dieses beispiel was
ist was ist das eigentlich für eine
verschwendung zum beispiel kunst und
kultur zu unterstützen
wer braucht wirklich diese konzerthäuser
diese opernhäuser man denke sich an
hamburg geht ein wunderbares konzert
haus gebaut haben die kosten x-mal
überzogen haben es ist es endlich fertig
geworden wie viele menschenleben hätte
man für dieses geld retten können
und jetzt hat halt das hamburger
bürgertum die möglichkeit sich dort hin
und wieder einberufen oder solchen
schönberg sein wenn ich so anfangen zu
denken er habe nicht so anfangen zu
denken
denke ich ist das auf der auf der einen
seite wirklich da tut jeder kultur und
auf der anderen seite ist aber wirklich
ein echtes problem damit benannt dass
man auch philosophisch bearbeiten muss
wenn ich das problem dass bestimmte
formen von kultur und gehört jetzt nicht
nur das konzerthaus oder die oper dazu
sagen vielleicht auf die schweizer luxus
uhr dass bestimmte formen von kultur
damit
überhaupt sich entwickeln können
ungerechte verhältnisse zur
voraussetzung haben nietzsche hat das
ganz klar formuliert ja die barbarei die
unmenschlichkeit ist schon wissen gerade
der nährboden von kultur walter benjamin
hat mal gesagt die kulturleistung ist
eine abgewogene untat ja und ich weiß
jetzt nicht da könnten wir jetzt wieder
so ein bisschen leben nichts heraus wenn
er weiß jetzt nicht oder eine welt die
noch dies und altruistisch ökonomischer
quantifizierung kriterien funktionierte
wirklich eine bessere welt wäre in einem
emphatischen sinn
und da kommen nur haben wir zu einem
eingangs bemerkung als subjektive
haltung ja ist das höchst respektabel
ob das pick im programm zur
weltverbesserung ist das war der
ausgangspunkt dieser fragestellung
das wird man immer zweifelhafter je
länger wir diskutieren ich würde das
ungern also ja kulturleistungen
kulturleistung wurden früher auch
geschaffen wo das elend noch tatsächlich
vor unserer tür war und trotzdem hat man
tolle konzerte geschaffen obwohl man
verhungern den massen sozusagen in
nächster nähe gesehen hat mittlerweile
sehen wir die nicht mehr also der mensch
ist offensichtlich riecht diese wir
sehen sie nicht mehr vor unserer tür wir
ja also wir haben sie nicht mehr so ganz
direkten kontakt der mensch ist
offensichtlich fähig davon zu
abstrahieren es fähig zu verdrängen das
ist unser grundprinzip als menschen und
natürlich baut unsere kultur darauf ich
würde trotzdem aus einer moralischen
sicht sagen es wäre eine bessere welt
die 12 weniger konzerthäuser hätte und
etwas weniger weltruhm aber würden sie
so weit gehen wie peter singer der ja
den musikproduzenten david geffen
öffentlich kritisiert hatte übrigens
auch an diesem sternstunden tisch vor
eineinhalb jahren habe ich mit ihm
darüber diskutiert david dessen hat die
avery fisher hall im lincoln center in
indien new york renovieren lassen ich
glaube 400 millionen dollar und peter
singer habe ich natürlich gesagt ist
absolut falsch
hätte man nicht tun sollen bewegen das
ist wie ein auto ist der anspruch der
höchst problematisch aber wir müssen uns
schon dieser fragestellung in diesem
konkreten fall glaube ich ging es darum
dass die akustik dieser konzerthalle
sehr problematisch war und alle
dirigenten und erst habe ich danke die
akustik ist
das ist eine katastrophe ich bin auch
ich schätze auch die musik aber die der
umbau haut 500 millionen dollar gekostet
und diese privatperson dave gahan hat
100 millionen dollar gespendet
wenn diese zahlen stimmen dass man damit
30.000 menschen das leben retten kann
dann aber ich denke das wäre auch zu
sagen wir leisten uns alle die schöne
akustik und da sterben die menschen also
ich ja gut ich glaube wir werden uns
nicht einig wie sind kurz vor
weihnachten meine letzte frage an sie
ist völlig klar sie werden ihrer frau
keine teure uhr schenken kriegt sie
trotzdem weihnachtsgeschenke hier
gespendet also ich und meine frau haben
ausgemacht dass wir uns zu weihnachten
nichts schenken aber ich schenke sonst
meinen freunden und verwandten auf jeden
fall etwas und meine frau hat jetzt in
den nächsten tag geburtstag und da wird
sie auch ein geschenk finden wir machen
dies mit ihren kindern billig spielzeug
und dafür spenden oder gibts das super
holzspielzeug aus diesem alter ist schon
fast auch wieder raus aber tatsächlich
hat in meiner familie gibt es wirklich
seit jahren diese abmachung es gibt
keine weihnachtsgeschenke dafür spenden
wäre es sind ist eine unter erwachsene
eine wirklich sinnvolle abmachung bei
den kindern kann was man sich nicht
durchhalten die müssen etwas kriegen
habe ich versuche es zumindest
ansatzweise nützlich und jetzt nicht so
in den großen finanziellen rahmen sein
zu lassen
die harmonie zynisch über die stränge ja
ich habe immer das getan hat mich
hinterher ganz schlecht fühle wenn man
dann irgendwie wenn man sozusagen diesem
konsens stört irgendwie auch moralisch
irgendwie nicht sehr gut dasteht also
ich verschenke weder öko spielzeug noch
ständig primär zu weihnachten
das mag eben sind mental einen effekt
sein aber wenn ich was verschenke wir
dann schon luxus und ich bin gespannt
was ich demnächst mache wenn ich mich um
weihnachtsgeschenke turnieren
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für diese
angeregte diskussion danke dass sie hier
waren ja und unsere philosophische
tipprunde die jeweils dem stammtisch
gehört finden sie auf unserer website
nächste woche spitze ich ganz genau die
ohren ich spreche mit dem star
dirigenten daniel barenboim über die
kunst des zuhörens eine fähigkeit die
wir in dieser zeit des lauten
geschätztes unterschritten behauptungen
gut ein bisschen trainieren können
und jetzt gleich geht's hier weiter mit
einem kunstkrimi wir zeigen einen film
über einen kunstfälscher der seit jahren
gefälschten bronzeskulpturen in den
kunstmarkt einschleust
ein bisschen schlitzohrigkeit nach der
moral pauke von heute kann vielleicht
nicht schaden
gute unterhaltung also um deinen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]